Hey podcast listeners, this episode has lots of jokes. Some people might find the jokes offensive. In fact, the thin line between being funny and being offensive is our theme today. If you're listening with the young kids, you might want to save this for later. I say a lot of absurd over-the-top things. Because if people see a train wreck possibly coming, absurd over the top things. Because if people see a train wreck possibly coming, they're gonna listen. Welcome to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam.
嘿，各位播客听众，这集节目有很多笑话。有些人可能会觉得这些笑话冒犯人。事实上，好笑和冒犯之间那条细微的界限就是我们今天的主题。如果你正和幼小的孩子一起收听，你可能想留到以后再听。我说了很多荒谬绝伦的话。因为如果人们预感到可能有一场灾难要发生，荒谬绝伦的话。因为如果人们预感到可能有一场灾难要发生，他们就会听下去。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
On today's episode, I'm going to give you a special technique to pure into someone else's head. It's using humor, the joke. What we laugh at, and what we don't laugh at, tell us very important things about ourselves and about other people. We got people lab coats examining dick jokes. Comedian Bill Burris here to help us explore why we laugh at jokes that push the boundaries.
在今天的节目中，我将教大家一种窥探别人大脑的特殊技巧。那就是利用幽默，也就是笑话。我们为什么发笑，为什么不发笑，能告诉我们关于自己和他人非常重要的信息。我们有穿着白大褂的人在研究关于生殖器的笑话。喜剧演员比尔·伯尔来到这里，帮助我们探讨为什么我们会对那些挑战界限的笑话发笑。
NPR's Elizabeth Blair join me for that conversation. It's coming up soon. But first, I want to tell you about some research into what makes people laugh. This is Robert Lynch. He's an evolutionary anthropologist. He studies how traits pass down through evolution affect human behavior. He now works at the University of Missouri. Instead of asking, do you prefer blacks or do you prefer whites? Or do you associate women more with career and men more with family or the reverse? You actually time them on how fast they categorize things on a keyboard. In the test he gave volunteers, he studied their associations on gender attitudes.
NPR的伊丽莎白·布莱尔和我一起进行了这次对话。节目马上就到。但在那之前，我想跟你们聊聊一些关于人类为什么会笑的研究。这位是罗伯特·林奇。他是一位进化人类学家。他研究通过进化传承下来的特征如何影响人类行为。他现在在密苏里大学工作。与其直接问你，你更喜欢黑人还是白人？或者你是否更多地将女性与职业联系在一起，而将男性与家庭联系在一起，反之亦然？你实际上是在测试他们把键盘上的东西分类的速度有多快。在他给志愿者的测试中，他研究了他们对性别态度的联想。
What's interesting about these associations is that they're often unconscious or implicit. People aren't aware of them. Lynch also had the volunteers listen to jokes related to gender issues, the comic he chose, Bilba. I got data this girl one time. She was like really into like women's issues. So we always have the dumb ass argument. So one time she came up to me and she goes,
关于这些联想，有趣的是它们往往是无意识的或内隐的。人们并没有意识到这一点。林奇还让志愿者听了与性别议题相关的笑话，他选定的喜剧演员是比尔·伯尔。我以前跟一个女孩约会过。她特别关注女性议题。所以我们总是吵那些愚蠢的架。所以有一次她走到我面前对我说：
okay, explain this to me, Bill. Why does a guy make more an hour to do the exact same job, huh? Mm-hmm. I'll tell you why, because in the unlikely event that we're both on a Titanic and it starts to sink, for some f***** up reason you get to leave with the kids and I have to stay. And that's why I get the dollar mark out. People laugh but there's a big range. Some people didn't at all. Some people almost falling out of their chairs.
好吧，给我解释一下，比尔。为什么干同样的工作，男人每小时赚得比女人多，嗯？嗯哼。我来告诉你为什么，因为在万一我们俩都在泰坦尼克号上而且船开始下沉的极不可能的情况下，出于某种该死的原因，你可以带着孩子离开，而我必须留下来。这就是为什么我能多赚一美元。人们笑了，但差距很大。有些人根本没笑。有些人差点从椅子上摔下来。
Now, if you asked people why they laughed or didn't, some people will tell you the joke was funny, and others will tell you it wasn't. But Lynch thinks something else is going on. People's unconscious attitudes about gender was strongly correlated with whether they laughed or found the joke offensive. The take-home message is that people who associated female with family and males with career more strongly had stereotypic or traditional gender preferences, it's called, tended to laugh more at that segment. The joke about men and women in other words is actually a test. If you watch the audience, as Bill tells that joke, you can get a pretty good sense of what's going on in the mind of the person who laughs, and the mind of the person who doesn't laugh. Lynch thinks there are strong evolutionary reasons people behave this way. In fact, he thinks humor itself may have evolved because
现在，如果你问人们他们为什么笑或为什么不笑，有些人会告诉你这个笑话很好笑，而另一些人会告诉你不好笑。但林奇认为事情没那么简单。人们对性别的无意识态度与他们是否觉得这个笑话好笑或被冒犯之间存在着强烈的相关性。核心结论是，那些将女性与家庭、男性与职业联系得更紧密的人——也就是所谓的具有刻板印象或传统性别偏好的人——往往会在那个片段笑得更多。换句话说，关于男人和女人的笑话其实是一个测试。如果你观察观众，当比尔讲那个笑话时，你可以很好地了解笑的人心里在想什么，以及不笑的人心里在想什么。林奇认为，人类之所以会有这种行为，背后有着强大的进化原因。事实上，他认为幽默本身之所以进化，可能是因为
it allows people to tell who belongs to their in-group and who doesn't. A lot of laughter is about taboo topics and things like that. So it's communicating something that we may not be so readily willing to admit, but we're communicating it to other people to find out if they share our preferences. And then if it doesn't work out, eh, it was just a joke, you know.
它能让人分辨出谁属于自己的内群体，谁不属于。很多笑话都围绕着禁忌话题之类的事情。所以它在传达某种我们可能不那么愿意轻易承认的东西，但我们把它传达给其他人，以找出他们是否与我们有相同的偏好。然后如果行不通，呃，那只是个笑话嘛，你知道的。
And so it's got this, it's kind of a coded message saying, hey, are you part of my group? Are we in the same in-group? And by laughing at that joke, you're maybe possibly signaling that, yeah, I think women are more associated with family. I mean, that's the lame way to say it, but that's, you're implying that you have
所以它带有这种色彩，这是一种加密信息，意思是，嘿，你是我的群体的一员吗？我们属于同一个内群体吗？而通过对那个笑话发笑，你可能是在暗示，是的，我认为女性与家庭联系得更紧密。我的意思是，用这种蹩脚的方式说出来不太好，但这就是，你在暗示你有
these stereotypical gender preferences or traditional, I should say. So in some ways, I think what I'm hearing you say is that for a very long time, we actually have been using jokes as a way to understand what's happening inside other people's heads. The joke has been a brain scan for much of human history. That's a good way to put it. Yeah. So unlike verbal communication, which is very susceptible to deception and lying. And oh yeah, no, I believe what you believe. Yeah, I'm on your team. Yeah yeah I'm in the same group laughter may be a way to honestly signal there's always an evolution kind of a need
这些刻板的性别偏好，或者说传统的偏好。所以在某种程度上，我想我听到你的意思是，在很长一段时间里，我们其实一直都在把笑话当作一种了解别人脑子里在想什么的方式。在人类历史的大部分时间里，笑话一直是一种脑部扫描仪。这样说很好。是的。所以，与非常容易受到欺骗和撒谎影响的言语交流不同。哦，是的，不，我相信你相信的。是的，我跟你是一伙的。对对对，我在同一个群体里，笑声可能是一种诚实发信号的方式，总有一种进化的需求
to signal things honestly when there's when they're so susceptible to deception. That's evolutionary anthropologist Robert Lynch. When we come back Elizabeth Blair is going to join me. We'll talk about how comedians need to skirt the edge of what's offensive in order to be funny. Sometimes that can mean going over the edge. Stay with us. Welcome back to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
当事物极易受到欺骗时，需要诚实地发出信号。这位是进化人类学家罗伯特·林奇。稍后伊丽莎白·布莱尔将加入我们的讨论。我们将探讨喜剧演员如何为了搞笑而游走在冒犯的边缘。有时这意味着越过红线。请继续收听。欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
I was talking about this idea, the idea that jokes can act like a brain scanner with Elizabeth Blair. Elizabeth is an arts reporter at NPR and she covers the world of stand-up comedy. Elizabeth, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks, Shankar. It's great to be here. I mean, this is a topic that is dear to my heart, because I love stand-up comedy, and I always thought there was a psychology, a science,
我一直在和伊丽莎白·布莱尔探讨这个想法，也就是笑话可以充当大脑扫描仪的想法。伊丽莎白是NPR的艺术记者，她负责报道单口喜剧的世界。伊丽莎白，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，尚卡尔。很高兴能来到这里。我的意思是，这是一个我非常关心的话题，因为我热爱单口喜剧，我一直认为其中存在着一种心理学、一门科学
behind why we laugh, why we wouldn't laugh, and I'm just very eager to hear more. And I remember we had this fantastic conversation a couple of months ago at Elizabeth. We were sitting on the fourth floor patio at NPR, playing clips from our favorite comedians, and not just listening to the comedians, but listening to ourselves, listening when it is we laugh and when it is we don't. And why we laughed and why we didn't.
支撑着我们为什么会笑，为什么不会笑，我非常渴望听到更多。我记得几个月前我们在伊丽莎白有过一次非常棒的对话。我们坐在NPR四楼的露台上，播放着我们最喜欢的喜剧演员的片段，不仅听喜剧演员在说什么，还倾听我们自己，倾听我们在什么时候发笑，什么时候没有发笑。以及我们为什么笑，为什么不笑。
And it wasn't always for the same reasons. No, it wasn't for the same reasons. I've actually brought in a couple of clips with me today at Elizabeth. I want you to listen less to the comedian and more to the audience's reactions to the comedian. The comedian is someone you're gonna know, Louis CK, I'm sure you're a fan. He's a master. And what he does in this series of clips
而且原因并不总是相同的。不，原因确实不尽相同。伊丽莎白，我今天其实带来了几个片段。我希望你少关注喜剧演员本身，多关注观众对喜剧演员的反应。这个喜剧演员你一定认识，路易·CK，我确信你是他的粉丝。他是个大师。他在这一系列片段中做的是
is he brings the audience very close to a place where they're gonna be very uncomfortable. Here's Louis. Everybody has a competition in their brain of good thoughts and bad thoughts. Hopefully the good thoughts win. For me I always have both. I have like the thing I believe, the good thing. That's the thing I believe. And then there's this thing. I don't believe it, but it is there. It's always this thing and then this thing, it's become a category in my brain that I call, of course, but maybe. I'll give you an example.
他把观众带到一个非常接近让他们感到极其不舒服的地方。这是路易。每个人的大脑中都存在着好思想和坏思想的竞争。希望好思想能赢。对我来说，我总是两者兼有。我有那种我相信的东西，好的东西。那是我相信的东西。然后还有这个东西。我不相信它，但它确实存在。总是这个东西然后又是那个东西，它成了我大脑中的一个类别，我称之为：当然，但也许。我给你举个例子。
Okay, like of course, children who have nut allergies need to be protected. Of course, we just segregate their food from nuts, have their medication available at all times, and anybody who manufactures or serves food needs to be aware of deadly nut allergies. Of course, but maybe, maybe if touching a nut kills you, you're supposed to die. So I love this transition between the of course and the maybe because the of course part is
好的，比如当然，对坚果过敏的儿童需要受到保护。当然，我们只要把他们的食物和坚果隔离开来，随时准备好他们的药物，任何生产或提供食物的人都需要意识到致命的坚果过敏。当然，但也许，也许如果碰到坚果会让你丧命，那你本来就该死。所以，我非常喜欢“当然”和“也许”之间的这种过渡，因为“当然”部分是
the part that we all agree, appropriate views, civilized views, and the maybe part is this part in our brain that sort of is lurking there hidden below the surface. But we don't speak it, we don't say it, because it's inappropriate, it's not polite. Exactly, and what I love is how Louis sort of pulling us closer and closer and closer to that line. So what he does is he walks us even further to the line in this next clip, here he is. Of course, slavery is the worst thing that ever happened.
我们都赞同的观点、得体的观点、文明的观点，而“也许”部分则是我们大脑中潜伏在水面之下的那一部分。但我们不会说出口，我们不会讲出来，因为它不得体，不够礼貌。没错，我喜欢的是路易如何一步步把我们拉得离那条线越来越近。所以在下一个片段中，他把我们带到了更接近那条线的地方，听听他是怎么说的。当然，奴隶制是有史以来发生的最糟糕的事情。
Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! Listen, listen, you all clapped for dead kids with a nuts. For kids dying from nuts, you applauded. So you're in this with me now, you understand?
噢！噢！噢！噢！噢！噢！噢！听着，听着，你们为那些对坚果过敏而死的孩子鼓掌了。对于因坚果而死的孩子，你们鼓掌了。所以你们现在跟我是一伙的了，明白吗？
You don't get to cherry-pick. Those kids did nothing to you. And you can hear the audience. The nerves are there. They're not quite bellowing anymore. But there's some laughter, but there's some sort of, I don't know if I can laugh at this. I totally agree.
你们不能挑肥拣瘦。那些孩子又没招惹你们。你能听到观众的声音。紧张感就在那里。他们不再大声呼喊了。但有一些笑声，还有一些类似“我不知道我能不能笑”的反应。我完全同意。
And it's almost as if he has actually trapped them because he actually brought them in, initially, with something that they basically said, OK, we'll walk with you. But now he's taken them to this really dark place. And what I like about this clip Elizabeth is that it reflects ideas that social scientists have talked about for more than a century.
而且就好像他实际上把他们给套路了，因为他最初用一件他们基本上表示“好吧，我们跟你走”的事情把他们吸引了进来。但现在他把他们带到了这个非常黑暗的地方。伊丽莎白，我喜欢这个片段的地方在于，它反映了社会科学家们讨论了一个多世纪的想法。
In 1905, Sigmund Freud wrote a book called Jokes and the Relation to the Unconscious. And one of the points he makes is that jokes are usually violations of deeply held to booze. So part of why a joke is funny is that it allows us to get up against this place in our brain that's really dark and really scary. Yeah, no, and that's one reason I love comedy.
1905年，西格蒙德·弗洛伊德写了一本名为《笑话及其与潜意识的关系》的书。他提出的观点之一是，笑话通常是对深层禁忌的违反。所以笑话之所以好笑，部分原因在于它允许我们面对大脑中非常黑暗、非常可怕的那个地方。是的，没错，这也是我热爱喜剧的原因之一。
I almost feel like when I walk out of a great show, it forces me to be a little more authentic with my feelings, I might not express them, but let's face it, we all do have some really dark thoughts. That's human. Yeah, and it's interesting you say that Elizabeth do have some really dark thoughts. That's human. Yeah, and it's interesting you say that Elizabeth, because in some ways Freud talks about this idea too, this idea that the joke actually offers us a mechanism for catharsis. It allows us to get out things in our cells that we really want to have come out.
我甚至觉得，当我看完一场精彩的演出走出来时，它迫使我对自己的感受更加真实一些，我可能不会把它们表达出来，但面对现实吧，我们所有人的确都有一些非常黑暗的想法。那是人性。是的，你这么说很有意思，伊丽莎白，确实都有一些非常黑暗的想法。那是人性。是的，你这么说很有意思，伊丽莎白，因为在某种程度上，弗洛伊德也探讨过这个观点，即笑话实际上为我们提供了一种宣泄的机制。它让我们能够把内心深处真正渴望释放的东西释放出来。
I was in Montreal recently at the Just for Last Festival, and I actually asked Margaret Cho about this very thing. Why do people laugh? Or what is it about comedy that sort of releases something? And this is what she said. It's kind of like they're laughing out of fear because you can't believe that you said it. I can't believe it. It's a kind of a fear, but it's also like that you're laughing because somebody is actually playing with fire and that this may erupt into something incredibly explosive. So here's where I might push back just a bit, Elizabeth. I came by some new research published recently
我最近在蒙特利尔参加“Just for Laughs”喜剧节，我实际上就这件事问了玛格丽特·曹。人们为什么会笑？或者喜剧有什么魔力能够释放某些东西？她是这么说的。这有点像他们因为恐惧而笑，因为你不敢相信你居然把它说出来了。我简直不敢相信。这是一种恐惧，但它也类似于你之所以在笑，是因为有人真的在玩火，而这可能会演变成某种极具爆炸性的东西。所以，伊丽莎白，我在这里可能要稍微反驳你一下。我最近看到了一些发表在
in one of the social science journals. It was worked by Peter McGraw. He's a behavioral scientist at the University of Colorado. And he makes the argument that really for a joke to work, it has to violate a taboo, it has to question or challenge something that we believe in. But it has to do it in a way that is actually safe. That if it actually questions this taboo in a way that's unsafe, or it gets too close to challenging something that's very close to our own heart,
社会科学期刊上的新研究。那是彼得·麦格劳（Peter McGraw）的研究成果。他是科罗拉多大学的一名行为科学家。他提出这样一个论点：实际上，一个笑话要想起作用，它必须违反禁忌，它必须质疑或挑战我们所信仰的东西。但它必须以一种实际上安全的方式来做到这一点。如果它以一种不安全的方式来质疑这个禁忌，或者它过于接近于挑战我们内心深处珍视的东西，
the joke stops being funny, it starts being offensive. I mean, if you're a parent of a child who has a nut allergy, that Louis CK joke, you probably are not laughing. Right, you probably find it disturbing, and this goes back to the idea that Robert Lynch told us at the start, which is what you find funny and what you don't, says a lot about what's happening inside your own head. Okay, we've talked a lot about the scientific research into humor. Let's bring a real comic on the stage. Hello. Is that Bill Burr? Yes, it's eight. We got in touch with Bill Burr to ask him about the thin line between being funny and being offensive. You've made me nervous for many, many years, so I'm
这个笑话就不再好笑了，它开始变得具有冒犯性。我的意思是，如果你是一个对坚果过敏的孩子的家长，路易·CK那个笑话，你大概是笑不出来的。没错，你可能会觉得它令人不安，这就回到了罗伯特·林奇在节目开始时告诉我们的观点，也就是你觉得什么好笑、什么不好笑，在很大程度上说明了你脑子里正在发生什么。好了，我们已经讨论了很多关于幽默的科学研究。让我们请一位真正的喜剧演员登台。你好。那是比尔·伯尔吗？是的，就是他。我们联系了比尔·伯尔，向他询问好笑与冒犯之间那条细微的界限。你让我感到紧张很多很多年了，所以我很高兴
delighted to be talking to you. Why? Your jokes have made me pure into my own soul, and I don't like what I see there. Well, you and me both. I'm talking about me, not you though. That's great. Elizabeth and I asked Bill about different jokes and the audience's reaction to them. Right, he did a joke on Conan about Bruce, now Caitlin Jenner. I miss that guy. I miss him already. You should have told us. He should have given us a chance to say goodbye. I'm not gonna watch him on the Olympics. I watched him on chips.
能跟你交谈。为什么？你的笑话让我审视自己的灵魂，而我并不喜欢我在那里看到的东西。好吧，你我彼此彼此。我说的是我，不是你。那太棒了。伊丽莎白和我向比尔询问了不同的笑话以及观众对它们的反应。没错，他在柯南的节目里讲了一个关于布鲁斯（现在是凯特琳·詹娜）的笑话。我想念那个家伙。我已经开始想念他了。你本该告诉我们的。他本该给我们一个说再见的机会。我才不在奥运会上看他。我看他在《急诊室的故事》里的演出。
I watched him on that horrible show. My wife, where he just walks around in the background. And then he's just like, and nobody listened to him. It was just, it was so sad. And then, I don't know, I don't know where. It's just, he just saw his guy. And he's, Kaylyn, then you couldn't react. You can't, couldn't on any level be like,
我看他在那个糟糕的节目里的演出。我的妻子，他只是在背景里走来走去。然后他就像是，而且根本没人听他说话。这真是，太令人悲伤了。然后，我不知道，我不知道在哪里。他只是看到了这个家伙。然后他是，凯特琳，然后你根本无法做出反应。你在任何层面上都无法表现得像是，
oh my go, you know, what the f, you on any level. You couldn't say that, or you automatically homophobic. Yeah. Dude, I didn't hear your inner thoughts i don't know what you were doing all of a sudden you just go did you shame your beard off people like oh my god that's your chin wow this guy walked out of the dude came back a woman he just goes with
噢，天哪，你知道的，这算什么鬼，你在任何层面上。你不能这么说，否则你自动就成了恐同者。是的。老兄，我听不到你内心的想法，我不知道你在干什么，你突然就说，你把胡子刮掉了？人们就像，噢，天哪，那是你的下巴，哇，这家伙走出去时是个大老爷们，回来时却变成了女人，他只是
oh yes anyway if Kalin has a good that's something i do during my act where i always lead people down a road where they're like, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, okay. It's a way, it's something that I kind of do subconsciously now, but it's something that I did when I was on my way up and people didn't know who I was. It was a way to keep the crowd interested because if people see a train wreck possibly coming, they're going to, they're going to listen.
哦，是的，无论如何，如果凯特琳有一个好……这是我在表演时经常做的事，我总是把人们引入一条死胡同，让他们觉得，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，好吧。这是一种方式，现在这已经成了我潜意识里会做的事，但这是我在刚出道、还没人认识我的时候就会做的事。这是一种保持观众兴趣的方式，因为如果人们预感到可能有一场灾难要发生，他们就会，就会听下去。
But Bill said he's listening to the audience too. Like the crowd is just this thing. I mean, you can't really see a lot of them, so it just becomes this thing that you're listening to. And just over the years of doing it, I guess you are making adjustments, but after a while it's like subconscious. You don't even know you're doing it. One of the bits from one of your Netflix specials that we were really interested in was your whole riff on domestic abuse. What do you think wife beaters are doing
但比尔说他也在倾听观众的反应。就像人群只是这样一个实体。我的意思是，你其实看不清他们大部分人，所以它只是变成了一个你在倾听的存在。多年表演下来，我想你确实在做调整，但过了一段时间，这就成了潜意识。你甚至不知道自己正在这样做。你的某个网飞（Netflix）专场里的一个段落让我们非常感兴趣，那就是你关于家庭暴力的整段碎碎念。你觉得虐妻的人在
when they drive home? They're like so focused on hitting their wife and they got blinders on, they're not reading anything. Do you remember the audience's reaction to some of the... Yeah, it killed. Right now it killed. But Shunker, the truth is, not everyone in the audience's reaction to some of the... Yeah, it killed. Right now it killed. But Chunker the Truth is not everyone in the audience thought so because there was also this reaction. Bill Boyd is still gonna do it. Did that get too weird for you guys? Bill said he intentionally takes the audience to an uncomfortable place.
开车回家的时候都在想什么？他们太专注于殴打他们的妻子了，他们戴着眼罩，根本没在看任何东西。你还记得观众对其中一些……的反应吗？是的，全场爆笑。当时全场爆笑。但尚卡尔，事实是，并非观众中的每个人对其中一些……的反应都是如此。是的，全场爆笑。但尚卡尔，事实是，并非观众中的每个人都这么想，因为也有这样的反应。比尔·伯尔还是要这么做。这事对你们来说是不是变得太诡异了？比尔说他故意把观众带到一个不舒服的地方。
So a lot of the times when I do my jokes, I deliberately have the setup. I leave it vague and almost just have, oh, where's he gonna go with this? Is it gonna, you know, was this going in a clan direction? Or is this going in a green piece direction? Yeah. So you kind of have them on the fence and they wanna see what the result is
所以很多时候我在讲笑话时，我刻意设计了铺垫。我把它说得模棱两可，几乎只是让人觉得，哦，他到底要扯到哪里去？这会，你知道的，这会朝着三K党（Klan）的方向发展吗？还是会朝着绿色和平组织（Greenpeace）的方向发展？是的。所以你有点让他们悬着，他们想看看结果是什么
and then hopefully they come along for the ride. I told Bill that some researchers think that jokes are a kind of brain scanner. That while he's trying to make an audience laugh, others are studying why the audience laughs. So what people laugh at and what they don't laugh at can actually tell you a lot about what's going on inside their heads. And you know, there was a... There was a there was a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a Yeah, I agree. Now, since Robert Lynch used Bill's humor about gender issues in his experiment, we decided
然后希望他们能跟着一起接受这个过程。我告诉比尔，一些研究人员认为笑话就像是一种大脑扫描仪。当他在试图逗笑观众时，其他人却在研究观众为什么会笑。所以人们笑什么、不笑什么，其实能告诉你很多关于他们脑子里在想什么的事情。你知道，曾经有一个……曾经有一个……
to go back to that subject. Yeah, we brought back the domestic violence bit, because when Bill performed this joke for one crowd, there was a very interesting response from the audience. So at the end of the hour, they come to the logical conclusion. They're like, there is no reason to hit a woman. There is no reason to hit a woman. And I was just like, really? I could give you like 17 right off the top of my head. You could wake me from a drunken
是的，我同意。既然罗伯特·林奇在他的实验中使用了比尔关于性别议题的幽默，我们决定
stupor. I could still give you like 9. Who does plenty of reasons to hit a woman. He just don't do it. But to sit there and suggest that there's no reason. The level of ego behind that statement, what are you levitating above the rest of us? You're never annoying. Women, how many times have you thought about slapping your f***ing guy in the head this week? There you go. I asked Bill why I found it funny when the woman talks about domestic violence in a way
回到这个话题上来。是的，我们重新拿出了家庭暴力的段落，因为当比尔向一群观众表演这个笑话时，观众产生了非常有趣的反应。所以在表演快结束时，他们得出了合乎逻辑的结论。他们觉得：没有任何理由去打女人。没有任何理由去打女人。我当时就想，真的吗？我随口就能说出17个理由。就算你在我喝得酩酊大醉时
I didn't find it funny when Bill joked about it. Because we're in different weight classes and generally speaking, unless you're fighting Ronda Rousey or one of those amazing athletes in the MMA or Laila Ali, like somebody knows how to fight, generally speaking, you know, guys, you know, can beat up a woman. So what's funny is it's the same thing if you see a little guy knock out a big guy. It's hilarious. If you see the big guy knock out the little guy, it's, it's awful. It doesn't make you feel good. So that's why, you know, it isn't really a double standard because they have to live in the fear of being hit. You know, I hate when guys go, oh, that's a double standard as far,
把我摇醒。我还是能说出大约9个。有很多理由可以打女人。只是你别去打就是了。但坐在那里暗示说毫无理由。这种言论背后的自恋程度，你是悬浮在我们所有人头顶之上吗？你难道从来不招人烦吗？女人们，这周你们有多少次动过狠狠扇你们的臭男人脑袋一巴掌的念头？看吧。我问比尔，为什么当女人以某种方式谈论家庭暴力时我觉得好笑，
I'm not saying you're saying this, but when they're like, you know, oh, they can joke about it, but I can't. It's like, yes, yes. That's like those weird white people that go, well, how come they can say it and we can't when they're talking about the end word, it's just like, dude, do you really not understand the whole dynamics of that? Bill's explanation perfectly mirrors what Peter McGraw's research has found. A woman talking about beating up a man feels like a benign violation because we know it doesn't happen that often.
而当比尔开玩笑时却不觉得好笑。因为我们的体重级别不同，而且一般来说，除非你在和隆达·鲁西（Ronda Rousey）或综合格斗（MMA）中那些了不起的运动员或莱拉·阿里（Laila Ali）打，也就是跟懂格斗的人打，否则一般来说，你知道的，男人们，你知道的，是能打过女人的。所以有趣的地方在于，这就跟你看到一个小个子击倒大个子一样。这太搞笑了。如果你看到大个子击倒小个子，那就，那就太糟糕了。这不会让你感觉良好。所以这就是为什么，你知道的，这其实并不是双重标准，因为女性必须生活在挨打的恐惧之中。你知道的，我很讨厌那些男的说什么“哦，这是双重标准”，就……我不是说你在这么说，但当他们觉得“哦，他们能拿这个开玩笑，而我不能”时，就像是，对，没错。这就好像那些奇怪的白人说：“怎么他们就能说那个词，而我们不能呢？”当他们谈论那个N开头的词时，就好像，老兄，你难道真的不理解这背后的整套动态逻辑吗？比尔的解释完美地呼应了彼得·麦格劳的研究发现。一个女人谈论痛殴一个男人会让人觉得是一种良性的违规，因为我们知道这种事并不常发生。
A man talking about beating up a woman feels offensive because we know that kind of thing happens all the time. You know, Shankar, one thing I didn't know about Bill Burr is that he actually likes hecklers. He doesn't like people who just yell, you suck all the time, but he actually likes people who don't agree with him. I say a lot of absurd over the top things. Like I really don't put any boundaries, I try not to anyways, on what I say. And then, you know, when I, when I do that men, women stuff,
一个男人谈论痛殴一个女人会让人觉得充满冒犯性，因为我们知道这种事经常发生。你知道的，尚卡尔，我对比尔·伯尔不太了解的一点是，他其实很喜欢那些挑衅起哄的人（hecklers）。他不喜欢那些只会一直大喊“你太烂了”的人，但他其实挺喜欢那些不同意他观点的人。我说了很多荒谬绝伦的话。就像我真的没有设什么界限，无论如何我尽量不对我说的话设限。然后，你知道的，当我，当我谈论那些男人女人的话题时，
I want women to yell stuff out, because I want to, you actually can learn stuff while you do a stand up, like how how they react their points that they make versus yours, you know, I mean, I've always said I don't read and I'm a moron so by all means, you know, I'd love to hear your opinion. All right, so Bill Burr is going to keep saying absurd things and you should all keep yelling things out, but I had one last question for him. Where do things go from here? I mean, so you've built such an impressive career and you've done keep yelling things out. But I had one last question for him. Where do things go from here? I mean, so you've built such an impressive career
我希望女人们大声喊出来，因为我想，你在进行单口喜剧表演时其实能学到东西，比如她们如何对你的观点做出反应，而你又如何回应她们，你知道的，我的意思是，我一直说我不读书，我就是个白痴，所以无论如何，你知道的，我很乐意听听你的高见。好吧，所以比尔·伯尔会继续说一些荒谬的话，你们也应该继续大喊大叫，但我对有一个最后的问题要问他。接下来事情会怎么发展？我的意思是，你已经建立起了如此令人瞩目的职业生涯，而且你已经完成了
and you've done so many different things. What's next on that horizon? I think this is the time where I start my drug habit. And then I screw the whole thing up. I hit rock bottom, I do a reality show, and then later on I write the book. Don't say that, Bill. And then I'll play somebody's grandfather on a sitcom. That's comedian Bill Burr. His new animated series, F Is For Family,
这么多不同的事情。地平线的下一站是什么？我想这是我开始染上毒瘾的时候。然后我把一切都搞砸了。我跌入谷底，我去做一个真人秀节目，然后过一段时间我再写本书。别这么说，比尔。然后我会在情景喜剧里扮演某人的爷爷。这位是喜剧演员比尔·伯尔。他的全新动画剧集《福是全家福》（F Is For Family）
premieres December 18 on Netflix. The Hidden Brain podcast is produced by Karam Agar Kalasin and Maggie Penman. Our new assistant is Max Nestrak, special thanks this week to Elizabeth Blair and Daniel Schuchin. Find us on Twitter, Facebook and Instagram and of course on your local public radio station. If you'd like to sign up for our newsletter, email us at hiddenbrainatnpr.org with the word subscribe in the subject line. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
将于12月18日在网飞首播。《隐藏的大脑》播客由卡拉姆·阿加尔·卡拉辛（Karam Agar Kalasin）和玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Penman）制作。我们的新助理是马克斯·内斯特拉克（Max Nestrak），本周特别感谢伊丽莎白·布莱尔和丹尼尔·舒钦（Daniel Schuchin）。请在推特、脸书和照片墙上关注我们，当然还有你当地的公共广播电台。如果你想注册我们的简讯，请发电子邮件至 hiddenbrainatnpr.org，并在主题行中写上“订阅”一词。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任何句子即可发表评论。